tonight's on a new home of NBC at 9:00
Eastern Time and he is a friend of the
program and I mean that not just a
friend of mine and Sue's but also the
man who played the replay guy in a
fantastic video for us last January
Jolla truly oh good to see you good to
see you I had such a fun time playing
that role
what a fun short and I hadn't been to
the I've been the Rose Bowl shot at the
Rose Bowl right you shot the Rose Bowl
you said was legendary I was on the
field you were on the field of the Rose
Bowl I felt like the 20 yard line guys
who who are you channeling as the replay
guy Joe I mean who are you who are you
trying to oh man bring to life I go to
in depth yeah yeah I was searching for I
think I was probably trying to bring in
some George see Scott sweet yeah some
you know that is an old-school young
sitcom man
yeah well that's also he's also the
first coach and Bad News Bears breaking
training he's the he's the ass at a you
and me guy he's that coach that's sweet
I've never put that all together yeah
that's why I'm here by the way and
that's my go-to reference for the
Astrodome
yes prairies breaking training yeah the
Astrodome yeah fun one I will go that
any day of the week
okay so there's so much to talk with you
about let's let's start let's start with
the Jets your New York Jets are you
happy with the hiring of Adam guys here
look yes because he's he's a guy that
I'm hoping yes well we'll lead our
quarterback to to the Hall of Fame he's
gonna be right there he's gonna take him
by the hand by the ticket and they're
gonna go in the Hall of Fame and take a
look yes
and then eventually Donald will get
there I don't know I I don't I don't
know juries habit you never know
I don't you never do no I don't want to
cut to the gates but like it
ions are taken I mean you you nailed him
well it's an open case situation it is I
guess they got it they got a case to
music and and either
I like Jets I like it's it well the
best-case scenario the best case is is
that Donald winds up in the Hall of Fame
yes
and there's a few trophies in the case
that's I don't know how much more Steve
Joe another best case scenario is that
if we take some of the AFC North maybe a
maybe your running back and a wide
receiver and we just bring them over
we just we the wide receivers not the
wide receivers not gonna happen
yeah I know it's the running back though
maybe levy on bail
look great in green and white and in the
collegiate level sure did I think that's
exactly where they're missing you know
for Sammy I mean we saw what what GaSe
was able to do with with I you know the
running back said he has there with a
gibe afore he he he jettisoned him yeah
another punt of the turn of the phrase
and Kenyan Drake against Belichick
that's the idea I mean if you can create
in MetLife what he was able to create in
Miami when Bella check went down there
good shape then you would at least you
would one out of every three against
right England yes bet he'll take it but
not out of every four look yeah
jury's out but I like that he's young
Jason and that I elect young coaches
I like the Rams coach like my NFC team
big Rams for now you are going this
weekend I'm gonna go to the game I'm
gonna go to the game I'm sitting amongst
the crowd you're a man of the people
I'm a man of the people you're are you a
season ticket holder I am okay I am did
you give any thought of putting your
tickets on the secondary market and
trying to reap the benefits of a cowboy
fan coming to town trying to get in that
building no no I I'm taking my brother
and my dad and I bought two other
tickets and taken some friends and no I
want to be there all Rams fans know the
two to two tickets are there Giants fans
so they're not rooting for the cow-house
one for the Cowboys and my my dad and my
brother were dolphin fans that we're all
from Florida I grew up in Florida say
but they're now going over to the Rams
so you are not allowing Cowboys fans
into the building through New York
through your large as secondary you're
not letting any Cowboys fans into the
Coliseum it's not gonna work to season
to tell others across the across our
pond over here have already sold some of
their tickets on the secondary ticket
market actually I did not sell any mind
I'm bringing four people for the Cowboys
now they're rooting all for the Rams
Chris Brockman of your allotment so now
you have two season tickets of your own
I have two a month as a season ticket
holder you were offered more tickets
that you collected for the sole purpose
of reaping some profit on the secondary
ticket more capitalist guys in front of
in LA together towel but streamed over
at that game we were all together yeah
huh that was a great game right that was
a legendary came you guys know the stats
so I was very exciting so if anybody
needs tickets already accounted for they
not I mean I still have a couple from
the back pocket he's polled as I told
him there's no doubt in my mind Jim
Jolla truly a Brooklyn nine-nine tonight
9:00 Eastern Time there's no doubt in my
mind it's not some sort of diehard Rams
fan out in Rancho Cucamonga saying you
know what let's just get a hotel room
for the night let's go down to the game
and all by Chris Brockman's two tickets
it's some cowboy fan coming in yeah
you're letting the enemy in the enemies
are at the gonna be silver Chris
agencies tell you like a lot of you know
the Green Bay game the Viking game the
Chiefs game a lot of fans gonna do
Purple's greens red oh you know they
were there in the Cowboys they're gonna
be there too they're gonna be there more
than the other ones yeah I'm telling you
yeah even more than the Packer fans the
panickin fans are I mean the Cowboys
fans are all and you they they're
training camp up in Oxnard I mean there
already is a Cowboys fan base here or is
there
and I didn't know here it's common man
I'm already talking to a buddy of mine
who's an eagle fan
I said listen mm-hmm if the miracle
happens in New Orleans you've got a
ticket my friend we'll go and we'll go
to the Coliseum yeah I just don't I
won't put mine on the secondary market
yeah see this is a man who has
principles this is a man who has
scruples this is a man just gonna leave
it at that
Chris I love capitalism good for you I
have definitely thought about how the
Eagles have that Destin feel right now
right yeah well they got nothing to lose
right and that it's the proverbial house
money to use that phrase as well
mm-hmm but I don't know if you heard and
your preps for tonight's premiere or
going about being a dad or whatever
uh-huh how Sean Payton fired up the
Saints I did I didn't hear he took their
Lombardi out of the case and got somehow
225 thousand dollars in American cash
which is the prize money for per player
for winning the Superbowl put it on a
cart of some sort got three members of
security I don't know if it's team
security security I have no idea what
but brought it all into the locker room
with the with the team gathered and say
who wants this everybody's like I do and
he's like then win three effing games
Wow good for Peyton I heard I'm like oh
my god I mean if he's putting it down
he's putting down the gauntlet right the
cash pile that's amazing that's amazing
well you know or you can have the Eagles
go there and just get that cash instead
that's the argument has that happened on
a set like does somebody put an Emmy
Award in the middle of Sandburg put the
globe he put it right Center the bullpen
he's like listen yeah funny ass ad lib
that's theirs and then we went for it
John for Cruz got it I mean yeah for me
it would be one of Bob Costas sports and
surrounded surrounded by craft service
you know I can't it's just
that is to me that you know to a sports
person food at a an event it's just it's
the best and then craft services when
you get it when you're on some sort of a
shoot Oh
that to me would be I've run through a
wall fence for really good craft service
for a nice sushi roll oh my god so
Brooklyn nine-nine tonight sir tonight
we're gonna back it's back we're gonna
we're gonna see Jake and Amy you know
celebrating their marriage we're gonna
see Boyle trying to get in on it
as always you know to be TBA on whether
that he's successful what was it like on
the first day of the shoot when you're
all back after you thought you were gone
and the fans pounded the table and
socialism here and you were saved we
were elated we get everyone got to the
stent we just kind of looked around
we're like we're still here this is all
great this is house money really it
anyway you're just and so you're kind of
charged and you want to do more of the
show that you've been doing yes and we
were always very grateful always very
excited about the show but but now we we
were truly thrilled to be still here and
and we every time we read the script now
at the table read it was always fun but
now we're like all the fans are gonna
love this oh they're gonna love that
joke that character saying that joke is
gonna be great it you just you get a
sense that the world is watching a
little bit more and it was I keep saying
we were thrilled because we truly were
we didn't expect to be there and we get
to do more of of what we love to do and
you know the regular fan the Joe and
Jane that went out there on on Twitter
and said this show cannot die and NBC
came and saved the show there were also
some very famous people that came out
did you know that
say for instance Mark Hamill that Luke
Skywalker was a fan of your program know
Mark Hamill lin-manuel Miranda Sean
Astin Guillermo del Toro just just I'm
forgetting another biggie and and it was
like a fan and a fan of these guys and
another fan of the show
we couldn't believe it I mean Scot Luke
Skywalker though Skywalker right sky
listen bring the show back I know and
and his his force worked these are not
the cancellations you're looking now
they're they're known as the guardians
of the galaxy those those I like or the
Cardin's of the 99 I do like that yeah I
do like that well congrats on all thank
you so much I really I'm fired up for
you and the rest of that cast and the
rest of that crew and although it is it
is run by a die-hard Patriot fan and
Mike sure I know I you know I know
personally as well it's okay they're
giving them for as doubt there is Ken
tremendous yeah I know if I just outed
him but I don't think so but I mean if
you had a patriot fan sitting there and
you're a die-hard jet fan and look any
any and he created a co-creator to show
about New York I mean if that's not
reaching across the aisle I don't know
what it understands what Josh how was
your fantasy season it started out great
and then had a quick turn I had a number
one pick out of 14 timur and went with
girly and and he was carrying me through
and I had breeze and Munoz one of those
things where I missed the by and and I
played another team with great matchups
and went out pretty early you know so
yeah I'm in the playoffs early and
breezed definitely had for the last four
weeks didn't even come close
yeah 12 yeah so it happens in the other
League I was saying to keeper League I
am with Mr Rudd came in third
so to team him that my team name is I'm
blanking my team name is the holy smokes
is it the sick bastards it might be a
sick bastard okay what's our what's the
avatar of the sick best it's cut it's a
guy with the googly eyes just like it's
just kind of like well run in a league
that Brockman and I he was the general
manager on draft night cuz it was the
the night of the season preview show for
NFL gameday morning in the NFL Network I
could not make it
he chose the groceries on draft night I
handled the roster week to week day-in
day-out ha ha we've won the we won the
the league as Paul Rudd gave the
blessing when he was here on the show he
gave the blessing to touch of the
Vermeil which is what you have when you
choked up we start tearing up yeah you
know a touch of the Vermeil you have a
touch that I know very well my mother's
very much know she has a touch of the
Vermeil
exactly that's so unfortunately so you
ran out of steam oh that's all right
yeah that's okay we'll get him next year
I got the Mayfield and chubby my keeper
League so I'm going on the brows so you
could yeah imagine that who is the last
person to say you know what I'm gonna
keep to Cleveland Browns yeah I think
that they're they've got it that hasn't
happened in a long time
a field how about this one I was gonna
ask this already let's let's let's go I
was gonna ask this earlier but we we
went off in other directions
who would you keep next year would you
take in fantasy based on the new hirings
right now
Mayfield hmm with Freddie kitchens again
or Bruce Arians and Jameis Winston I
think you jig if you have a baker in the
kitchens you're not gonna you're not
gonna go wrong with Jameis Winston and
Bruce OJ Howard and Mike Evans and
Jameis who can throw for 300 yards a lot
more often than Mayfield doesn't have
the running and now Aryans is just an
absolute madman who's just gonna go
vertical who would you choose over that
I'm biased I mean I still like Baker
how about Baker or Aaron Rodgers with
Matt Lafleur think about what Rodgers
was this year I know he's got banged up
and he got hurt who would you take
fantasy was right there for that you
gotta sit here and wonder about it Chris
and I still take Aaron Rodgers I think
I'd have no right to wonder if Mayfield
is gonna run it back like that and then
Sam darn 'old with Adam GaSe Sam Adam
darn we'll need some better weapons or
I'll do respect to Robby Anderson or its
Fugazi I know it's when I got to see it
that's oh that's nice okay we've got we
we got that on my Twitter feed sent by a
fan saying just in case it doesn't work
out instead of worst case scenario
Fugazi there's the what the headline
would look like
his face on Tony Soprano Jets players
mutiny foo Casey oh that's beautiful
we're gonna post that on our absolutely
that is a great Steve Lee special
tonight at 9:00 Eastern Time Brian
nine-nine is back thanks so much for
coming here Joel thank you so much for
having me you were the man brother
yeah thanks thank you thank you again
for doing that video for time for
funnier does bring them back I would
love it bring them back
well the replay guys you know got more
more on his plate yeah never yeah
whatever and we'll just have to see how
he handles the pressure freak racks
under it or not the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience